[Music]
they perform every Sunday morning the
Vienna Boys Choir in a few moments
they'll be singing at this mass in the
Vienna hofburg cappella
[Music]
they had their first rehearsal at 8 a.m.
Joel is exhausted his friend Orion is
coping better the church is full to the
rafters this is a tradition popular with
both tourists and locals in Vienna
[Music]
the choirboys are young children but
they represent the continuation of a
centuries-old tradition Joel and Dorian
have put on their winter coats and hats
over their sailors suits the traditional
winter uniform of a Vienna Boys Choir
member when they're out and about in the
city for tourists a perfect photo
opportunity Vienna is a dream location
for visitors old beautiful baroque
traditional just like the Boys Choir
Jerald vert artistic director and
president of the choir takes us to a
nearby cafe the Vienna Boys Choir is one
of the most successful children's choirs
in the world he says boys choirs are a
big attraction in general one reason is
because young children are singing very
demanding music at the highest possible
level and that's something that
fascinates the public as well as other
artists conductors and singers and also
a lot of composers many of whom have
always composed and written for this
medium company Lincoln Imam Joel is from
Malaysia he always wanted to be in the
boys choir and his parents agreed Dorian
is 12 and he has been with the choir
since kindergarten
he says it's difficult to say what it's
like in other schools because I'm only
used to this one and I like it
we want to get to know the boys better
so we give them our camera and they set
off with it through the beauty of Vienna
we ask them to show us this city and
their lives here
Joel decides to interview Dorian and
asks him about his favorite tour Ossian
Asia but also America who says I can't
decide there are so many great tours the
opportunity to travel the world is one
of the perks of the choir max do you
like snow yes I do particularly because
there's no snow in Malaysia for me it's
still something really special Joel says
so he's a little bit sad that there's
been no snow so far this Christmas
season Zeus is curtain right now at
school doing just bomb cooling have been
Lipa do you have your favorite place in
Vienna
John isn't sure but he definitely likes
the Christmas market durian is much more
certain my favorite place is home he
says
you can see the city hall there
and up there is the rat house man that's
awesome and there is the Parliament the
building housing the Vienna Boys Choir
school is no less magnificent the out
garden palace is where the boys live and
learn alongside around a hundred other
choir members aged between nine and
fourteen this is our room says Dorian
they're just ordinary boys the boys
choir is keen to share its image as an
elite group that's certainly what they
were in the kaisers era but there's a
whole educational concept behind singing
in the choir being part of the community
is more important than being a gifted
singer the choir offers the children a
lot of support and a lot to eat we had
been a sausage today says Dorian and
kaiserschmarrn pancakes tomorrow I don't
know but it'll probably be something
good the same the school used to have a
reputation as an extremely strict
educational establishment the boys choir
was founded more than 500 years ago it's
always had a very conservative image at
least up until the 1960s but even in
these time-honored halls
times have changed Garrard vert is
giving voice training lessons
[Music]
[Music]
let this desease hear this phenomenon
the phenomenal thing about singing
gerald vet says something we probably
often forget how many positive side
effects there are of singing lessons and
singing together some years ago the
Vienna Boys Choir also began passing on
its knowledge to the outside world
tutors from the choir gives singing
lessons at schools in Austria and other
countries Raphael Nara is one of them
you can do it
the program is called super are
[Music]
the aim is to give socially
disadvantaged children a sense of
self-confidence and sometimes they also
find new talents for the choir and
sometimes these children also get to
appear on proper stages the super our
choirs are popular it's about accepting
yourself as you are as Raphael and
realizing that you couldn't do something
at first but afterwards you can and it's
not something abstract that you can
write into a school exercise book it's
something you show it's about trusting
yourself to sing in front of the class
to make a mistake laugh about it and
then everyone keeps singing Joel is back
in class this should be a maths lesson
but today they're making Christmas stars
for many boys this is their first
experience of a Christian culture we
asked Joel where the Christmas is also
celebrated in Malaysia he says yes but
not like here it doesn't have any
Christian meaning for some families
because Malaysia is a Muslim country
he says durian is puzzling over his
English lessons some of the boys are
good at school others not so good just
like everywhere else
Tina Bret felt gives us a tour of the
boarding school
she's the choirs archivist drama Turk
and a lot more besides this is the
tailor's shop
Tina shows us the uniform worn by the
youngest choir boys she came to be in a
15 years ago and has been working for
the Boys Choir ever since
and one victory Amancio me if you can
stir emotions with what you do you also
move yourself she says that's such a
feeling of happiness that I think that
one just wants to keep reproducing it
the children learn that very quickly
feeling of success a feeling of
happiness and by nurturing happiness in
others it increases your own and that's
a really nice effect does this that's a
severe issue no egg
[Music]
evening choir practice Joel and Dorian
are in the hidin choir there are four
choirs in all two are always on tour and
two at the school around a third of the
boys come from countries other than
Austria
[Music]
[Music]
practice usually ends at 6 p.m. the boys
have some free time and the opportunity
to speak with their parents
Joel finds a quiet corner with good
Wi-Fi reception
he hasn't been in touch with home for
six weeks it's often more difficult for
the parents than the boys that they are
so far away most of the boys try to
remain cool when they talk about their
parents we can't look into their hearts
but we wonder if it's really so good for
them to leave home so early but it's
impossible to miss their enthusiasm when
they are singing and performing in their
spare time the boys like to listen to
pop music or heavy metal maybe Joel will
go on to sing in a band when their
voices break the boys time in the choir
is over but the things that they have
learned here and experienced on their
tours around the world will always stay
with them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]